Hello everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Loops. And
today I'm joined by doctors Darcia Narvaez and Gay
Bradshaw. Doctor Darcia Narvaez is a Professor of Psychology
Merit at the University of Notre Dame. And Doctor
G Bradshaw is a psychologist and Ecologist and director
of the Kulu Center for Nonviolence. And today we're
focusing on their book. They Evolved Nest Nature's Way
of raising Children and creating connected communities. So, welcome
to the show. It's a pleasure to have you
both
on. Great to be here.
So I would like to start by asking what
is exactly the premise of the book and what
is an evolved next?
Well, every animal has a nest for uh raising
its young. It's a developmental system that has uh
been shaped through evolution to optimize normal development. And
so these are uh just part of our adaptation
as animals
a and are these uh species specific or are
they or are there some commonalities across species?
There are commonalities and differences too? So it's uh
that's what's fun about the book is that we
note the similarities and then we point out, oh,
look at how they do it, that this animal
species does it this way and, and that kind
of thing. So, uh it's just a um a
way of raising the young that is about nurturance
and meeting the needs of the young, the basic
needs without delay, without, you know, depending on the
species, what that means and to foster a sense
of connectedness of safety, of security and of uh
physiological, mental, psychological well being. Yeah, I think what
the book does is really uh cements what has
been known in uh Western science for hundreds of
years actually. But in particular, the last decades when
neuroscience has come to the fore and that's that
all animals and now there's going to be including
the data and theory and experimentation on plants, trees,
et cetera that we all share the same um
capacities and structures of the brain or of the
system that gives us the capacity to think, feel
love and dream and all of those things. So
that's really been known, but it's been quite tacit
and this particular book and, and our collaboration really
has shown that there's a uh that we're all
the same. It, it's rather than differences. The emphasis
is on diversity. So when you're saying, is there
species specific? Yes, there is just like there are
among human cultures. And I think that that's probably
the the the best way to uh uh readers
and listeners to approach. This is saying oh, you
know, we're all the same and yet we interact
and we express our interactions and experiences where we
live in our, our history in different ways, just
as we look at different human cultures.
So there are very different aspects of child rearing
and our uh individuals from the same family or
community, establish relationships among themselves that you explore in
the book. We don't have time here, of course,
to get into all of them. But let's get
perhaps into a few examples. So could you tell
us perhaps how mothers and all mothers uh the
role they play basically in, for example, African elephant
societies?
Well, I'll start in Darsha, you can, you can
fill in with things. Um African elephants are a
prime example. They've been extremely well studied by science
and um a lot of people have a lot
of humans have a lot of affinity for them.
Um Just to clarify alo mother, uh mother usually
refers to the, the individual, what we would call
the biological or the primary um caregiver that is
female that would nurse, et cetera and give birth
to an individual. Um Ala mothers are um other
mothers and that is really the uh the norm
among most human societies, traditionally, as well as uh
animal um societies. So in the African elephants is
that a baby is born from to a particular
female elephant. And prior to the birth um that
mother and the baby who's in the mother is
immersed in this constellation of aloe mothers, other mothers,
there are siblings, there's, you know, teenagers, there's cousins
and babies and they're really this sort of organism
that moves around and, and uh is there to
support the mother prior to the birthing which takes
two years in, in African elephants at gestation. And,
and afterwards, so immediately when the baby is uh
comes into the world from the mother's womb, uh
he or she is literally surrounded by other elephants
and family members and supporters. So you have seamless
connection um of being in this community. And, and
I think as we go on it really in
the sense of looking at the evolved nest and
child rearing and childbirthing, et cetera. The implicit, which
really should be made more explicit is the um
the need and the role of a community. So
it's not just the mother, it's not just the
father, it's really a community effort of which the
focal element of course, is the birthing, the birthing
mother or birthing parent and, and the child.
And of course, 00 yeah, go ahead. Sorry.
Yeah, it's interesting that our species uh we are
apes. Uh We come from uh shared lineages with
monkeys earlier and monkeys tend to share and have
fowl mothering going on uh other nurturers and they
share their babies around, but all the other apes
except us uh keep uh it's just a mother
that keeps her child because she doesn't trust the
others. Uh And that they evolved then to just
have mothers taking care of their young. But humans,
we brought back the aloe mothering in it according
to the evolutionary um ethology uh data. And that's
really important for us because it actually shapes the
brain to be much more flexible in social relations.
Because if you're only with one mother, at least
for humans, you tend to be much more rigid
about how to get along with others because you
only have practice with one really, you know, in
the first years. So you want to have a
set of, of nurturers, people who are spons. Uh
It's good for the baby, but it's also good
for a mother because babies, the evolved nest is,
you know, rather demanding for, in terms of baby
care. Uh We are like fetuses when we're born,
fetuses of other animals for at least the 18
months, uh the 1st 18 months of uh of
age. And so babies need to feel like they're
still in the womb. Uh And that requires a
lot of holding and moms just can't do it
all. It's like what? So that's why our species
perhaps went back to this collective uh child raising.
And uh the anthropologists tell us that it actually
shaped our big social brain to have cooperated child
raising so that we could have uh others providing
the many calories we need to be to build
a big brain.
So you mentioned holding the baby there, what is
the importance of physical contact for the baby? And
also by the way for the mother or the
other people who take care of
it. Well, in uh the neuroscience is telling us
that the touch is central to helping establish uh
well functioning uh biological systems like the vagus nerve,
uh the 10th cranial nerve that innervates all the
major systems of the body. And it's being uh
it's also fostered by breastfeeding. Uh And um but
touch is really important for that. And if you
don't get the vagus nerve well established, you might
have then health problems of various kinds later, you
know, digestive issues, uh heart uh lung issues, brain
seizures, that kind of thing. When the vagus nerve
is malfunctioning, it's also the uh Oxytocin system. You
want the endocrine system systems to be established properly
and touch really has a lot to do with
that. You wanna have that cuddle hormone that carries
you forward. So you, you know, you actually like
to be with people and like to touch them
and feel comforted by that. So there's many different
neurobiological aspects that are are um affected by touch.
It's calming it. Uh OF course, is gonna have
epigenetic effects, turning genes on and off that are
gonna be oriented to good health and touch needs
to be positive touch, not negative touch. We've got
a lot of data now on how even spanking
uh a, a child is like uh physical abuse
or emotional abuse in its long term effects, making
the individual more aggressive, less empathic and sensitive to
others. I think even at, at a deeper level,
when we look at um touch and we look
at the aloe mothering or the alo parenting, um
it really underscores that we're not these isolated units
that essentially, yes, there is an individual that comes
into the world, but that's like a piece of
a bigger puzzle or a piece of the tapestry.
And so what we see on the outside, you
know what Darsha was explaining and then looking from
the neural sciences perspective, what's happening on the inside
from a science perspective is really a reflection of
the reality of oneness and connection, even if it
is in the case of the brown bear. That's
a chapter in our book. Um There isn't an
Aloe family per se, it's a mother bear uh
who births the babies. And uh it's the hibernation
den, which is really the sort of the equivalent
of the Aloe mothering elephants, et cetera. But it's
really the environment. And so in, in another way
too, it erases the difference between social and ecological,
those are just sort of different elements of the
same theme. So there is this uh continuity, there
is this coherence and, and we see that as
expressed in terms of what Darsh is describing as,
as touch and positive touch in that way. So,
you know, it, it goes beyond the material. And
the neuroscience is, is just one way of sort
of keeping track of what those little pieces are
from the perspective of what science in our culture,
modern culture has relied on, which is dualism. But
really, we're looking at non dual consciousness, we're really
looking at this um coherence of oneness.
So we've mentioned mothers and mothers here. What about
grandmothers and the other older people in the community?
What is basically the role played by elders in
human and nonhuman societies?
Well, they are part of the Aloe parents allo
mothers, other nurturers, right? And uh there is a
grandmother hypothesis that the reason that women, human, human
um women uh exist to live beyond menopause is
so that they can take care of the young
because again, the young are young, need a lot
of calories. And, and there's data showing that when
you have the grandmother around the mother's mother, Children
do better, they have uh more, you know, better
health and so on. So that's uh kind of
more of a anthropological view. The uh indigenous perspective
of course, is that elders hold the wisdom of
the community and they uh they are repositories and
they have all the stories and experiences that help
the community uh survive and thrive wherever they are.
So it's very landscape specific. The language is from
the landscape and uh they are essential for the
well being of the community and their care of
the very young Children is just ideal because they
both are sort of still in tune or attuned
to the UN manifest realm, the spiritual realm and,
and they're not so focused on, you know, working
and like, uh adults are so they really get
along well and, and the grandparents are much more
forgiving and less rigid and so on with the
very young so that actually knits together the community.
And when the native Americans uh in Canada and
the US uh were um considered savage and the
governments wanted to break down, make them, you know,
kill the Indian and save the soul. They broke
up those relationships, taking the Children away and it
really devastated the communities because the elders didn't have
the young as an anchor for themselves and the
young didn't have that community to foster their culture
and language and so on. So the intergenerational violence
uh continues uh from those horrible genocidal uh treatments.
Uh And of course, when we talk about child
rearing, we tend to focus a lot on the
mother and sometimes also other females. But what about
the father? Could you tell us perhaps about the
example of Emperor Penguins and the role that fathers
play there.
We love Emperor Penguins. Of course, I'll start off.
Um Yeah, I think a lot of people, they've
been popularized in movies I've heard and things like
that. But the Emperor Penguins live in the Antarctic
and they're around 4 ft high. And just a
kind of a cartoon sketch of, of the community
is that the mother, the mother and the father
meet and they form partnerships and make love. And
then the mother produces this amazing single egg and
it's very, very cold there. The conditions are very,
very harsh. And so she eventually lays the egg
and is essentially when she does that, it's almost
immediately passed to the father who is um now
receives the egg and immediately puts it under his
feathers in this pouch. And the purpose of that
is because the the extreme cold there, the wind
chill factors makes it even greater and he takes
care of the egg while the egg is becoming
a baby and the mothers um they live in
a colony, I mean, there's all these individual pairs
and different relationships but they are within a, a
community. Uh It's a colony and the mothers essentially
all leave at that time, they birth roughly probably
at the same time and they go up to
a couple kom a couple 100 kilometers away off
the ice and into the ocean. And that is
to replenish because all of their energies has been
diverted and, and directed toward creating the egg and
all the nutrients and psychological, emotional everything has. So
this is going off to replenish and they spend
a couple of months there diving and looking for
fish and, and uh resting up and replenishing in
the meanwhile, the fathers are gathering, they each have
an egg. Uh AND again, it's very protected and
they gather in what's called a huddle, which are
a group of, of uh fathers. And they do
that. Um YOU know, well, from a physical perspective
is that because it retains warmth, it becomes this
kind of thermal unit by which the temperatures of
the egg can be kept perfect, not too hot,
not too cold. And in order to do that,
they actually move, you know, in, in a very
choreographed way to the interior of the huddle and
then some go to the outside. So again, this
is this co ordination. Again, this is a community
so that there's a baby, but it's a community
and then the baby is born and at that
time, the mother returns and essentially, then the fathers
go off and they are also depleted. Um Some
have lost half their weight, they go to the
ocean and replete and then they come back and
it's a very emotional and very intense time because
typically the colonies are in the thousands and they
have to find their mother and their wife and
child. So, um doctor Andre who's in France is
a researcher talks very beautifully about this that um
they're very mindful. So again, we're talking about a
community and this is an important point because they're
all coordinating together. There isn't this notion of competition
there isn't this notion of me first or anything
like that. Um They give particular calls, they each
have their own idiolect call. And if, if the
guy next to you is calling for his, they
wait for, until that person can call and identify.
So eventually they're all uh brought back together and
they uh form a, a family and it's very
much, um the term is co parenting. So, so
there's a very much coordinate at many scales between
the mother and the father, including the egg and
then the mothers with the mothers and the fathers
with the fathers. And then again, as the baby
matures, then there is a crash uh uh uh
uh you know, a kind of a coalescing of
all the young chicks, um you know, kind of
like a kindergarten or whatever, but they're all together,
there really isn't any kind of separation. And the
other idea is that connection is with community nonparent
and, and with each other in that way. So
it, again, this is just an example and we
have examples uh in the chapter on gray wolves,
which is different, but it, there does show the
participation of the, of the um of, of males
and same with the elephants. So I'll just put
that in real quick is um that uh the
baby elephants in Africa, they grow up in that
Natal family we described and then when they're, you
know, 1112, 13, they are either pushed out or
they go out and they join, um, uh, older
males, what they call an all bull group or
area. And they spend at least 15 years, um,
in association with this bull society, male society. So
there is not that kind of segregation that we
see. We see this very much cooper and I
would say just not even a division. It's just
everyone has the same goal and they work with
each other to make it work in the best
way possible for the babies and each other.
Mhm uh And so I guess that one very
important topic also to talk about here is attachment
theory. I guess it is very important in the
context of your book as was originally developed, I
think by Doctor John Bulby and then over the
decades further developed by other researchers and scholar. So
what would you say are perhaps some of the
main insights that we got from attachment theory when
it comes to having a better understanding of perhaps
the social needs that we and other species might
have and how we establish social relationships with other
people.
I'll start uh attachment has to do with relation,
relational belonging, essentially and connectedness and maintaining that um
those years when the brain is growing so quickly
that, you know, it's, it's setting up its worldview,
its sense of self, its sense of relationships. And
so uh the uh attachment promoting care which is
evolve nest, then establish this this deep sense of
security and safety and relation and, and skilled, knowing
how to, you know, stop and start relationships or
conversations and recognizing who's trustworthy and um just being
able to maintain relationships across time, babies have to
learn a lot of non verbal skills before language
comes about around age two. And a lot of
that is this relational kind of socio emotional intelligence.
So it has also to do with your own
uh understanding of your own emotions and conveying those
in ways that are appropriate um with your uh
relational experience in the moment?
A and is it uh just about, or is
it even primarily about the mother infant diet or
does it go beyond that? Because I mean, at
least when we commonly hear about attachment and attachment
theory, it's it tends to be mostly focused on
the mother, sometimes the other caregivers like the father,
for example, but people do not at least commonly
talk about other kinds of social relationships. But if
I understand it correctly, it goes beyond that.
Right. Right. So in Western civilization, which has become
patriarchal uh and emphasize the nuclear family, all you
have is mom, dad and the Children, right, the
emphasis of Western scholars has been to look at
the mother child diet because that's the framework, the
assumption that that's normal, but that isn't normal for
our species. Our species raised Children in multiple aged,
multi gender groups. And so really the way I
look at it is, mother provides the first attachment
and then she's the bridge to the attachment to
everyone else around. So that even in some uh
societies, I think the booty, the the infant after
a few days is passed around uh to the
group, uh whatever size it is and the baby
starts to get a sense of different smells and
different uh patterns of movement and gets comfortable with
all that and and builds a really a a
very a fabric supportive care around them. So they,
and they become attached even more than just to
people, to the natural world, around them, to the
animals and plants that they live with and uh
interact with. And so it's much broader, this attachment,
this sense of being belonging and connected and relationally
um kind of supported than what the Westerners uh
are studying and talk about.
But what are essentially the factors that lead to
the development of a secure attachment style and not
uh let's say non secure attachment style that could
be an anxious, violent or disorganized kind of attachment
style,
but it has to do with the predictability of
the caregivers. So providing the evolved nest, so providing
breastfeeding when the child signals they want uh touch.
When in our ancestral context, nomadic foraging communities, babies
aren't put down, they're carried everywhere because they know
uh they had intuitions about how that baby is
so vulnerable and required such uh intensive care of
uh to develop well. And so the baby is
having um relationships that are um always responsive and
nurturing in terms of touch and just listening and
emotionally honest and delightful. And in those situations, the
baby learns that everything is, you know, you can
predict it and um I'm safe and these people
are trustworthy and all that insecure attachment comes from
un inconsistent care. Uh We, and we uh see
that not in nomadic foraging communities unless there's been
some horrible accident or something. Uh But in modern
culture where babies are kind of, you know, more
like possessions than objects of control. And uh when
babies are left alone or left to cry, uh
and isolated physically, they're not gonna feel that sense
of belonging and safety and security. And so we
unfortunately have cultural myths about how important it is
to make babies independent, you know, and oh, you're
gonna spoil the baby if you pick them up
too much and all these crazy ideas uh that
actually undermine health for the long term. So when
you can, when you uh build an insecure attachment,
which could be anxious or avoiding depending on uh
exactly when and how you were treated when you're
insecure you, uh it means your neurobiology has been
shaped to be, you know, kind of disregulation and
you don't maybe know how to make friends and
you don't know how to maintain a friendship and
you don't know how to recognize a trustworthy relationship.
And so it gets you into all sorts of
trouble. Uh PROF uh professors tend to have avoidant
attachment, which is this detached way of looking at
things not emotionally available because that's how, what they
experienced as babies. And so it's very easy to
go in the Ivory Tower and make up stuff,
you know, and then apply your, you know, your
little model to the world. Maybe it works, maybe
it doesn't, but you get a publication and, you
know, you're not committed and emotionally attuned. Um And
so we've created a world where we reward that
kind of um avoid an attachment uh with, you
know, status and such and that's destructive to the
planet. It's destructive to nature because we're not relationally
attuned with our emotions, with our commitment, with our
moral commitment to the well being of everyone human
and nonhuman around us. And, and I would say
that um John boldly really made quite a contribution
because he really made visible, the invisible, which was
this notion of the importance of relationship and the
quality of relationship. But within that, again, this is
not a criticism because that's a it's a step
in the evolution of the western cultures way of
looking at things. You're still having one thing attaching
to another thing. And when you look through the
lens of nonhuman nature, everyone's attached, there is no
attachment, there are no strings, it's all one big
soup. So quote, unquote, attachment is just the way
animals live. And so that the, the specificity of
it, for example, the, the importance of the mother
with the nursing, the way Darsha was discussing it
or the, the, the way that the, the passing
of the egg with the father, those are important
elements, but it's all everyone's attached. It's the non
attachment that um Darsha was talking about in the
sense of some kind of perturbation, some kind of,
you know, causing a gap or schism between you
and me. Um OR you know, the baby and
the parent or whatever that is, that's the anomaly.
And, and essentially so, like I said, when we
look from through the baseline of nonhuman nature, there
is no attachment. It's we, we are all attached
and that's really what we're coming back into. And
um and, and the work that we've done together
is really trying to bridge that and, and move
us into this paradigm of the baseline of we're
all attached. We, we are, we just are in
that way. So the evolved nest is about meeting
basic needs, everyone's basic needs. There's no argument about
meeting the needs that you just provide and that
and nature's gift economy is that way too. You
take the fruit and then you, you, your waste
becomes some other animals uh food. And uh it's
just this ongoing cycle of giving and taking and
giving without uh a sense of disconnection, right? You're
just in it like uh gay said in a
soup and what the Western world has done is
just divided and disconnected all over the place, disconnected
body from mind, uh spirit from uh humanity. Uh
It's just a, a big mess of division that
I, we hope our book will help people realize
that that's not the way we evolved to be
and that's not helpful for the planet. And then,
yeah, go ahead and just real quick. I think
what's a challenge? And we're hoping as Darsha said
that the book will help, you know, support people
make that shift is essentially from one paradigm of
dualism. We can call it dualism pieces. You know,
all the pieces. You me, they, we all those
things into oneness into non dualism. And it really
takes um either an experience or a leap of
faith. But you, you, you at one point, you
have to kind of jump in, you have to
jump in and say, do we see ourselves as
you and me and separate that we're putting together
an assemblage? Or are we just one of which
I'm an expression? You're an expression of a part,
et cetera. And that's really what this is an
example of, of, of um encouraging people to jump
into that new view because then the other pieces
like the elements of the evolved nest, they just
kind of come out naturally. I mean, there may
be some questions like, well, how do I do
this? How do I transition, you know, I don't
have a grandparent or whatever, but then solutions start
to come up. OK? We don't have grandparents, but
we have our neighbors. Let's start to talk with
our neighbors and create this kind of um you
know, mosaic um that, that, that moves into to
oneness. So we're talking about in inter being, right?
We are all uh you are me, I am
you, it's uh there's no real separation. We're just,
you know, little uh pieces of the whole, the
implicate order and our uh ability to de differentiate
ourselves to see how we're alike, to see how
we are connected. And all in this flowing dynamic
universe is really our aim here and the animal
uh images and how they, they know this, right?
We have so much to learn from our animal
kin. Uh And so we hope that's what the
book will. Uh
But at a certain point there, you mentioned uh
needs uh what are needs exactly or perhaps a
better question is where do they come from exactly
what constitutes a child's in need? And I mean,
since uh of course, in the book, we explore
other nonhuman species, uh does that mean that perhaps
some of the of these needs are quote unquote,
hard wired or uh are there are Children perhaps
at least to some extent responsive to the eco
uh the ecology they develop in uh when it
comes to developing their own specific
needs? Well, the way I look at it and
gay can uh add her perception. Uh THE way
I look at it is that we're animals. And
so we all need some nourishment. We need shelter,
we need protection, we need warmth, uh or else
we die, right? But, but we're also mammals, social
mammals and we need affection to grow. Well, we
need the touch, right? We need play to grow
well, so basic needs to grow the optimal uh
kind of member of the species. That's what you
want to meet. And that's we have to identify
uh basic needs by what leads to optimality. And
we also are humans, we need to have meaning
uh and make meaning. And so the stories that
our culture tells us, guides our behavior and guides
our, our desires, our experiences build our desires, right?
To be close and affectionate or distant and detached,
right? Depending on the kind of early experience you
had. So basic needs really lead to optimization of
the individual and the community. Now, uh Maslow has
had his hierarchy of needs. He learned he got
inspired by the Blackfoot nation, the six AA. And
unfortunately, he turned it upside down because for the
Blackfoot self actualization is fundamental in primary and that's
what the evolved N does. For each individual. It
fosters your uniqueness, you can unfold and blossom because
all your needs are being mad and everybody loves
you and you feel like you belong. But he
put that as the end point, the end point
for the Blackfoot is cultural perpetuity community well being
so that the culture will, and that means the
bio community that in, in which you're entangled is
going to live into the future seven generations, right?
And we, you know, uh Maslow got very individualistic,
which is the western way instead of this communal
orientation that, that understands that we don't become our
best selves unless we have those basic needs met
all along the way throughout life.
Mhm A and what I, in what ways can
early life experiences have far reaching impacts?
Well, that's what I write about uh quite a
bit uh in terms of morality. Um BUT it's
also social capacities. So uh as I mentioned earlier,
within secure attachment, you're kind of uh hampered, you
have a uh inability unless you heal it later
with some interventions. Uh YOU get along that well
with others. Now, my work looks at how our
early experience, if you stress a baby so that
they learn to be uh threat, reactive, stress, reactive
because they've been stressed so much that stress response
is easily triggered, that's gonna shape how they act
with others and their moral decisions. What's right? What's
wrong? And in the moment, they'll be more likely
to feel afraid and brace against others, brace against
life instead of being open hearted and flexible, you
know, and attuned. So, uh that's gonna affect how
they think about the world, they'll be more likely
to have, uh, scripted, rigid ideas of black and
white up and down, more oriented to dominance hierarchies.
You know, either you're either up or you're down,
you're either a winner or a loser, that kind
of orientation. And each moment they can bring, uh,
if they feel unsafe in the moment they're gonna
go into that mode and their, their morality then
is gonna affect everyone else. I mean, we're seeing
far reaching, we're experiencing the far reaching effects of,
of early development. I mean, if you look at
the history of, of humanity over the last, we'll
just say 102 100 years, uh it has been
violent, it has been breaking down, it's been um
insecure attachment, generating writ large and none of that
has been processed. So when you have someone who
is severely traumatized um through genocide, through poverty, through
the industrial technological development, which has gotten intensified. Um
THE, the they're, they're thrust back into it and
there really is an Ame or of there isn't
a um a healing, a receiving healing community. So
even though a baby is brought up in a
certain that's obviously very critical. But the community, in
other words, the culture has to be one that
uh supports that individual. And if they're not, if
they're the same thing in a sense, you just
continue on this very, very destructive path, which is
what we see right now. And unfortunately, in the
nonhuman world. That's why you're seeing PTSD complex ptsd
just to use technical terms among African elephants never
existed. Nothing like that. The orc is off Spain,
nothing like that. And, and so, you know, we,
we can just analyze it from a very narrow
view of neuropsychology. But essentially, you're seeing this profound
ricocheting of, you know, one child experiencing insecure attachment
and then it perpetuating, perpetuating, perpetuating without any kind
of balance in terms of healing that individual. And
there are individual cultures, human cultures that have a
very different way when an individual uh for whatever
reason, um sort of steps out the bounds of
morality, what do they do? They do not expel
that individual, they gather around, they absorb, it's inclusive.
And again, what Darsha was talking is about that
inter being, it's our responsibility for that person, that
individual. And so that's, you know, these are elements
of socialism, right? Where it has to do with
the fact of that um your poverty or my
poverty or their poverty or their problem, quote unquote
is my problem. So it's a very different what
this is really saying is is that in order
for us to uh heal, in order for us
to bring cohesion and well being back on the
planet within our species and then the entire planet,
which is made chaotic by our human behavior is
that we have to be inclusive. We don't shut
them away in prisons, we don't stick people away
and get rid of them, we bring them back
and a number of the indigenous societies, that's how
they function. They, they, they sort of, you know,
absorb that individual. And again, that's another lesson of
the evolved nest. It's not just a person with
a mother or with a father, it's um, it's
an organism. So, really, although we talk a lot
about child raising and things like that, it really
comes down to, um, revitalizing those elements of the
evolved nest which are in, I think chapter 10
or whatever, they're sort of listed. I mean, they're
not, they're just kind of pointers to something which
is much of a, but that's really the focus
is that, that's how we can start on the
path, that's how we can break the cycle.
Mhm. Uh And do you think that perhaps some
of the issues that we are experiencing in industrialized
and post industrial societies nowadays have to do with
some of these more individualistic values that we have
where people are raised to think that perhaps they
shouldn't uh try to depend so much on others
and there's not so much the sense of community.
Uh I mean, uh also because I guess that,
uh uh looking at our own evolutionary history and,
uh, and other species, we are very much dependent
on others. And I mean, that idea that the,
just an isolated individual, uh and, uh, and the,
if it's not that then you're like spoiled or
something like that and you are just completely over
dependent on others. I mean, that's uh incorrect.
That's it. It's particularly strong here, I think in
the United States. Um, AND I think it's unfortunately
spread but it, it's considered something negative or bad
to say I need, I need to something, you
know, can you help me out? Um, THERE'S a
lot of shame associated with that and for the
rejection. So you get this spiral. So, you know,
to show kind of vulnerability is really considered to
be something is used on as, as, as prey.
We have a predator, we've developed a predatorial culture.
So when there's someone who is, who shows vulnerability,
um they're rejected and they are uh preyed upon
in, in that way. So again, the elements of
the that are, you know, sort of itemized in
the evolved nest to highlight certain things really are
um paths and principles which can really help our
culture. Um Our species return to, I would believe
it's, it's natural goodness where you want to call
it in in that way. So I can add
a little bit more um when we under care
for chil young Children. So don't provide the nest,
we're undermining the development of the right hemisphere, the
right hemisphere is scheduled to grow more rapidly. And
it's the part of our brain that is oriented
to dynamic relationships and living things and has a
sense of uh it's the seed of our self-regulation
initially and empathy and higher consciousness. And when we
under care for Children, that's uh you know, not
developed so well. And then they have to rely
on the survival systems that are innate so that
dominance, uh submission and territoriality and rivalry things. Um
PART of the reptilian brain, right? Um I mean,
it's insulting reptiles but um and then we send
them to school and train their left brain. Left
brain is all in the ego consciousness. It thinks
it knows everything, it doesn't know very much. It's
good at linear, you know, kind of analysis, but
it can't deal with dynamism, it likes static objects,
things it can measure, you know, and so the
western world has been taken over by the left
hemisphere and this is Ian mcgilchrist Point and is
running us, of course into the grave because we
forgot how to develop, how to foster an integrated
brain. Both halves are really important. But we have
now put ourselves in the hands of this very
detached robotic part of ourselves and guided by survival
systems, you know. So predation is part of the
left brain's orientation, manipulation of the world. Yeah. And
as, as Dar brought up the, the, the notion
of the reptilian brain is kind of an artifact
from science that reptiles, uh tortoises and alligators, rattlesnakes,
they all have the same brain that we do
and they all show uh the same what we
would call prosocial behavior, they care for each other's
young. They are non a grass, um, they're very,
um, community oriented and, um, they don't strike in
violence except, you know, when it's absolutely necessary. And
so, you know, those are the kinds of myths
which is also, have come along with, this is,
um, uh, separating ourselves. Oh, we're not like them
now, whether that's another animal or whether it's another
human and valor these aspects that, of the left
brain in the, in the language of neuroscience that
Darsh has been talking about and that's very, very
deep conditioning. So in the case of, you know,
that this is this whole, you know, schooling the
world, you know, even if you brought up, you
know, um and, and I can have personal experience
growing if you grow up in an evolved nest
kind of situation, but you're shunted into this conveyor
belt of um you know, II I it's kind
of a sociopathy, you know, where you're basically punished
in various ways and not just physical but socially,
all those things you're conditioned into letting go of
the right brain into uh into sort of squelching
these wonderful and beautiful feelings inside that are natural,
which seed and nurture those uh um within those
that you, that you meet. So we're, we're put
into this conveyor belt and then that becomes a
matter of quote unquote survival. If you're not like
this, then you don't belong and you're excluded. And
unfortunately, it's evolved to such a system where it
really comes down to, are you with us or
are you against us? We see that in political
systems, we see that in social systems, et cetera.
So it's really this move to um you know,
taking back our wholeness, taking back ourselves. And in
that, which is critical is understanding that nonhumans, that's
why it works for billions of years. That's why
nature has worked for billions of years. And so
we can say, OK, I'm, I'm gonna side with
them. I'm gonna side with nature. I wanna be
more like nature, I wanna be more like the
penguins. I wanna be more like the wolves and
by making that kind of solidarity, that kind of
commitment saying those are my people, these are my
kin then that in itself opens up an incredible
amount of the life force that really is responsible
for creating this incredible planet that we live on.
Mhm So I would like to ask you now,
since in the book, you talk a lot about
what we can learn from traditional societies, indigenous societies,
for example, uh because in modern industrialized and post
industrial societies, even with the issues that we have.
Uh SOME of them we've talked here about today,
um we still have many positive things like for
example, some very positive technological advancements that make our
lives better and easier. So I would like to
ask you, how do you think we could perhaps
strike a balance here between some of the positives
of those more traditional societies without perhaps having to
ditch, uh, the other positive things that we have
in our, uh, industrialized societies.
Well, I think, um, it's a tough question actually,
but there are traditional societies who weren't nomadic foragers
who have lived with localization where they have their,
you know, they raise their own food, they, they
have their own energy. They have, they use the
cycle of, of life on their farms, right? So
the waste from the animals or themselves goes into
the garden and grows as the natural uh fertilizer.
So they, they're not poisoning the the soil, they're
not dishonoring uh this the earth and they have
ways of being that are tuned in to the
well being of that landscape right there. So I
think we have to go back to these small
kind of communities and then perhaps with the renewable
energies, we can still maintain zoom conversations, for example,
those are nice.
Yeah, I would like to keep having
those. Yeah, but we don't need so much. I
mean, there's so much wastefulness um in our because
it makes money for people and it raises the
G GDP, right? The more you waste. So we
have to get back to understanding that we are
relational uh beings and every um plant animal river
mountain is part of our kin and we need
to be concerned about their well being and not
be greedy for what we think we need. But
you know, the early under care is gonna lead
us to be more greedy and trying to make
up for that hole we have in our heart
from disconnection from uh disrespected um early childhood. So
we have to kind of work at multiple levels.
Bring back the evolved n for the young re
nest, the adults get them calmed down, get them
more tuned in to the the cosmos, to their
relational responsibilities, feel more at ease and at peace
being a member of the earth community.
Uh And so perhaps just one last question and
I have asked you about traditional society. So when
comparing ourselves to other animals and we've gone through
several examples here today. Uh WHAT do you think
we can learn from them that would be applicable
to human societies?
Well, I'll continue with what Darsha said. Um I
don't think we need any of the things that
we call um human achievements. I mean, all of
those things are prosthetics that are substitutes for what
the evolved nest and the rest of nature lives
by and provides. Um I mean, zoom. Zoom is
wonderful because we get to meet you and each
other and, and things like that. But uh if
we were living together and whatever, we, we don't
need that. I mean, I may not, I may
have never met you. Um WHICH would be sad,
but at the same time, how sad. I mean,
in other words, they, what we, there's so much
loss that is uh associated with the things that
we think have gained us. I see these as
this is their intermediate steps and that we need
to give up those kinds of things. They, they
really, they keep us, I mean, right now, they
provide an incredible ability to kind of revitalize and
communicate and kind of get back to where we
are. But none of the rest of the other
species need what we say we need and they
do very well and they're very happy. So all
the things we cherish, like wellness and good relationships
and security and peace. That's what the animal world
has without modern humans. And so if it really
gets down to that, I think we just really
need to sort of say, well, we don't really
need all these things. These are just transitional objects
that move us into what Darsha was talking about.
Um AND life will be much better. So II,
I think it's not just um I think, I
think we need to aspire to be who the
animals are and who the trees and the plants
are. And those with those with insecure attachment tend
to be quite restless. They don't feel at ease
and because of course, they didn't, they didn't get
their needs met. And so they, they're anxious, you
know, where am I gonna get them met? And
so you try all these things, addictions and various
things to try to calm down. Um, BUT if,
if we provide the evolved nest or when we
have nested lives, we have a fullness of now.
We feel connected to everything now and we see
all the dynamism and we can hardly, you know,
look away from the beauty of, of life. Whereas
when you have an under cared for, under nested
person, they're worried and they're, you're thinking about the
past. Oh, I did all that wrong and they're
depressed about that and then they're worried about the
future and all and they're hardly in the present
moment because they didn't get enough practice for it.
They couldn't, I mean, it was too painful to
be in the present moment. They had to dissociate
when they were left alone to cry or left
alone, abandoned in some way. Uh So we have
to get back to the fullness of right hemisphere
functioning, the full integrated brain where we feel uh
this life is so beautiful and we are all
in it together and let's, you know, sing, let's
dance, let's play together. That's what we aim for.
That's, that's the flourishing human community that we um
see as our promise, we can still return to
that. Uh And so that's what we aim for.
And I think we see that um individually, I
think everyone, why it feels so nice to be
in nature. Hey, there, there are no TV. S
there are no iphones. Um, JUST being in nature
and then also just things like, um, I mean,
not everyone but a lot of people have fun
having a picnic or have fun going camping. Well,
that's because there's not all those things. Right. And,
and there is that so that those are sort
of touch points and, and indicators that that's our
natural, that's our natural path, that's our natural inclination
to well being and peace. So we can all
go find a sit spot near us where we
can tune into nature and go there regularly and
that'll open up our senses. We can all uh
be um activists for our local rivers, creeks, forests,
um trees, animals, native animals. Uh YOU know, it
just get out there and be committed to the
bio community that you're a member of.
Great. So I think that's a great message to
end the interview on. Uh THE book is again
the Evolved Nest Nature's way of raising Children and
creating connected communities. I'm leaving a link to it
in the description box of this interview. Uh And
by the way, would you like to tell people
apart from the book where they can find you
and your work on the internet?
Uh The Evolve Nest Evolve nest.org. And we have
a movie on this uh that's based in this
book. It's uh eight minutes long there. And there's
a couple other movies too that you can watch
free. No, it's a nonprofit So there's different tools
for re nesting. We have an evolved nest curriculum
you can do on your own to learn about
and then apply evolve nest principles and our um
website where there's material as well as uh Kulas.
It's www dot Kos K er Ul os.org and
that's the Kula Center for Nonviolence. So theres information
there.
Great. So I'm adding that also to the description
of the interview and doctors Narvaez and Bradshaw. Thank
you so much again for taking the time to
come on the show. It's been a real pleasure
to talk to
you. Thank you, Ricardo. Thank you so much. Good
to see you.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you like what I'm doing, please
consider supporting the show on Patreon and paypal. The
links are in the description down below and also
please share like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by N Lights learning
and development. Then differently check their website at N
lights.com. I would also like to give a thank
you to my main patrons and papal supporters per
Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Sun Bernard Seche Olaf,
Alex Adam Castle Matthew Whittenberg, Arno of Tim Hollowing,
Eric Aleni John Connors Philip for Connolly. Then the
Metro Robert Winde INAs Yu Mar Nevs Colin Holbrook,
Simon Columbus, Phil, Governor Mikel Stormer Samuel Andre Francis
for Agns Fergal Cousin Hall Herz RGN. Michel, Jonathan
lebron Jars and Samuel K Eric Heinz Mar Smith
J We Hummel sad friends. David Sloan Wilson Yas
de Ro Di NP please. Nicole Barbaro, Adam Hunt.
Pablo Stassi Alek Bach Ma he s of Zal
Adrian Yi Paulin John Bar. Poo Julian Price Hall,
Eden Bruner Douglas Fry Franco Beto Lotti Gabriel Cortez
or Lolis Scott Zachary Fish, Tim Da and Smith
John Wilman, Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke
Lo the Chris Williams and Peter Walla and David
Williams the Costa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Show,
Marie Martinez Coral Chevalier, Bangalore Larry Dey junior, Old
Herring, Starry Michael Bay. Then Spur by Robert Grassy
Zorn, Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radis Mark Temple,
Thomas Dubner and Luke Ni Andre to Kimberly Johnson,
Benjamin Gilbert Jessica Nowicki Linda Brandon Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensley Man. George Tori is Valentin Steinman, Paul Crowley
Kate Von Goler, Alexander Hubbard, Liam Donaway Biar Masoud
Ali Mohammadi Perpendicular Jonas Herner. Slow. Good enough, Gregory
Hastings and David Pins of a special thanks to
my producers is our web, Jim Frank Lucas Stina,
Tom Ween, Bernard, Nic Ortiz Dixon Benedict Muller Thomas
Trumble Catherine and Patrick Tobin Jean Carlo Montenegro, Al
Nick Ortiz Nick Golden and Rosie. And to my
executive producers, Matthew Lavender, Serge Adrian and Bogdan Kenny.
Thank you for all.